It's time for a pick from the little yellow book,
which is my personal guide of things that I love that
I think you might want to know about.
But today, we're here with Audrina Bigos!
From CBS 2, Chicago's morning news.
She's been with us throughout the entire show and Audrina,
you're going to put a pick into the
little yellow book today.
Yes, we are coming from Chicago,
it's the perfect fall treat.
We're in that mode, straight from the windy city.
So this is pumpkin spice coffee
from Chicago French Press.
What I love about this is that it's female owned,
it's black owned.
They make this in small batches.
It's with medium roast coffee beans from El Salvador.
The pumpkin spice that you're
going to taste is made in house.
And the coffee has notes of nutmeg and cloves.
All those things that make us feel so good inside.
And I wanted to taste it together.
All right, ready?
1, 2, 3. Here we go.
Don't burn your mouth.
I know. I hope I don't.
(lip smacking)
Hmm, let me tell you something.
You know what I love about this?
It's not too pumpkiny.
No.
Right it doesn't go bam in your face.
That's not a word,
but you understand what I'm saying? Right.
You know what I like is that often times,
so I'm new to coffee,
and I really like creamer with coffee in it.
Basically I just want the sugar, right?
So this, you get that pumpkin, nice flavors,
so you don't have to just douse it with sugar and cream
and all of that.
It's very, mmm, that's what I'm having
a hard time describing, but I really like it.
And it's very, very, very delicious.
So what's cool about this is that they have a give back
component, grinding with the cause.
So 5% of proceeds go back to a 501 C3.
They go back to nonprofits in Chicago and
around the country.
And I just love that so many Chicago businesses are showing
love back to our community.
Yes!
We need hope.
(audience clapping)
Good for Chicago.
I love it.
Yes so cool.
I just love organizations and businesses that go back to
supporting that. To giving back.
Audrina Bigos you are just the best.
This is the beginning of a beautiful friendship.
Yes, I love it.
(audience clapping)
I mean seriously, thank you so much.
Thanks for having me y'all.
It's so great to have you here.
Thanks for tasting all the goods with me from Chicago.
Oh, no problem.
Okay.
So thank you so much for choosing to spend
your time with us today.
We make this show for you.
So take this good energy with you,
and we hope to see you again tomorrow.
Thank you!